lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en que el tipo de reacción
obtendremos si tenemos prácticamente los
mismos ingredientes pero en lugar de
tener este núcleo filo med occ sí o esta
base me toc si tenemos algo un poquito
más envuelto vamos a seguir teniendo un
oxígeno con carga negativa
enlazado con un carbono pero ahora este
carbono va a estar enlazado con otros
tres grupos metilo ch3
h 3
h 3 entonces ya no tenemos el método
xxxii ahora tenemos a esta molecular
pero seguimos teniendo un solvente a
práctico y eso nos dice directamente que
se trata de una reacción s n 2 o 2 pero
ahora ya no tenemos el met ox y ahora
tenemos esta molécula de aquí y el med
occ si era una base extremadamente
fuerte pero además era una molécula muy
pequeña y entonces voy a meterse en casi
cualquier lugar y reaccionar con el
substrato entonces también era un muy
buen núcleo a filo ahora tenemos esta
otra molécula de aquí que es mucho más
voluminosa y que tiene problemas para
reaccionar con el substrato ya no es un
buen núcleo filo sigue siendo una base
extremadamente fuerte ya no es un buen
núcleo filo entonces si hacemos la base
más voluminosa deja de ser un buen
núcleo filo ok aunque bueno tal vez
debería decir
si hacemos que un núcleo filo sea más
voluminoso entonces deja de ser un buen
núcleo filo y por lo tanto ya no podemos
tener una reacción de tipo s n 2 en sí
es que solo cambiando ligeramente la
base o el núcleo filo cambiamos la
dirección de la reacción y ahora seguro
es una reacción de tipo 2 ok ahora sí
seguro obtenemos una reacción de 2 así
es que no veríamos esta reacción ok
sólo veríamos esta reacción ahora claro
que esta base de aquí tampoco se vería
así porque tenemos que borrar esta parte
y esta parte porque ahora en lugar de
estar enlazado con un grupo metilo está
enlazado con un carbono que tiene otros
tres grupos metilo
grupo metilo y grupo metilo y también le
puede llamar de butilo pero bueno aquí
también tenemos otros tres grupos metilo
ch3 y ch3 y la reacción sucede de la
misma forma sólo que ahora esta base
fuerte es más voluminosa porque hay pero
de todas formas este oxígeno le regala
un electrón a este hidrógeno este
hidrógeno deja su electrón que se va con
este carbono el carbono alfa y entonces
el bromo se va de la molécula con su
carga negativa y ahora es una unión
bromuro entonces tenemos exactamente el
mismo mecanismo solo que ahora tenemos
esta otra base que es más voluminosa y
que ya no es un buen núcleo filo y por
lo tanto no tenemos esta otra reacción
sn 2 sólo vamos a observar la reacción
de 2